This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world.
这是一个I-Heart播客。百分之二（Guaranteed Human. 2%）。这就是当有自动扶梯可用时，仍然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特（Michael Easter）。在我的播客节目《2%》中，我将剖析在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中，培养心理韧性、健身和建立抗压能力的科学。
Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO. percent on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me.
经历一些艰难困苦，你就会浴火重生，成为一个更快乐、更有成就感、更健康的人。请收听《2%》。也就是数字 2，在 IHeart Radio 应用程序、Apple Podcasts 或您获取播客的任何地方收听。在《回顾历史（Look Back at It）》播客中。从1979年开始，对我和说那是个重要的时刻。84年对我来说意义重大。
I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people.
我是山姆·J（Sam J）。我是亚历克斯·英格利ッシュ（Alex English）。每一集，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试着理解我们是如何度过那段时期的。与我们的朋友、同行喜剧演员以及最喜爱的作家一起。就像马克·拉蒙特·希尔（Mark Lamont Hill）谈论 80 年代那样。84年是一个疯狂的年份。这是一个疯狂的年份。我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的年份了。
Listen to look back at it on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hard Way with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that doesn't. not mean that you need to.
请在 IHeartRadio 应用程序、Apple Podcasts 或您获取播客的任何地方收听《Look Back at It》。嘿，大家好，你们好吗？欢迎收听《艰难学步（Learn the Hard Way）》，我是你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人科尔·盖姆斯（Kear Games）。这个空间是关于黑人男性的经历，进行诚实的对话，而在其他任何地方进行这些对话其实都是不安全的，但你是在与一个知道自己在做什么的持证专业人士进行对话。有多少男人穿着盔甲。它向世界发出信号，表明你是不好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你需要这样做。
Listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Owens, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, a lesbian.
请在 AHA 广播应用程序、Apple Podcasts 或您获取播客的任何地方收听《Learn the Hard Way》。2023年，《单身汉（Bachelor）》明星克莱顿·埃克德（Clayton Eckerd）被指控生下了一对双胞胎。但这次怀孕似乎是个骗局。欧文斯女士，你伪造了这份特定的测试两次，对吗？我伪造了一次测试。这需要一大群互联网侦探来揭开一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男士。格雷格，一个女同性恋。
Michael Mancini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hello everybody and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through some of the big life changes and transitions of our 20s and what they mean.
迈克尔·曼奇尼（Michael Mancini）。我的脑子炸了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨（Stephanie Young）。这是《深陷爱河（Love Trapped）》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面对了后果。在 IHeart Radio 应用程序、Apple Podcasts 或您获取播客的任何地方收听《Love Trapped》播客。大家好，欢迎回到《你的二十多岁心理学（The Psychology of Your 20s）》，在这个播客中，我们将探讨二十多岁时的一些重大生活变化和转型，以及它们的含义。
for our psychology. Hello everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast, new listeners, old listeners, wherever you are in the world. It is so great to have you here back for another episode as we of course break down the psychology of our 20s. Every few years, I feel like a new form of therapy rises to the surface,
对于我们的心理学。大家好。欢迎回到节目中。欢迎回到播客，新听众，老听众，无论你身在世界何处。非常高兴你能回到这里收听另一集，当然我们要剖析我们二十多岁的心理学。每隔几年，我感觉都会有一种新的治疗形式浮出水面，
A new form of mental health treatment, a new wellness practice becomes the new it thing. A couple of years ago, it was like in a child healing and that's still very relevant, but everyone was very obsessed with it. Reiki was another one, somatic release was another one that people got really, really obsessed with. And when that happens, there is this like real chance that we can become really kind of misinformed or that we can think that one mode of dealing with emotional and mental issues is the only mode that we should be pursuing that everything else is was that came before it was false and breath work might just be the new it thing i feel like i've been hearing about it everywhere everyone
一种新的心理健康治疗方法，一种新的健康实践成为了新的流行事物。几年前，就像是内省童年疗法（inner child healing），这仍然非常相关，但每个人都对此非常着迷。灵气（Reiki）是另一种，躯体释放（somatic release）是另一种让人们变得非常非常着迷的方法。当这种情况发生时，确实存在一种真正的可能，那就是我们可能会变得非常误解，或者我们可能会认为处理情感和心理问题的某种模式是我们应该追求的唯一模式，之前的一切都是假的，而呼吸法（breath work）可能刚刚成为新的流行事物，我觉得我到处都能听到关于它的消息，每个人
is talking about it i know it can be so incredibly powerful but i'm a little bit skeptical I've done a little bit of research on my own, but I thought, you know what, let's talk to an expert. I feel like other people in their 20s, other people in general will have questions about all the dialogue they see online or the recommendations they may be hearing from other people about the power of breathwork. So we're going to talk about what it actually is, how it works, how it operates according to science, how it can go hand in hand with more modern day practices and therapeutic approaches. and also its traditional and ancient roots. And of course, we're bringing on an expert who is here with us right now. Hello, Jessica. Welcome to the show.
都在谈论它，我知道它可以非常强大，但我有点怀疑。我自己做了一些研究，但我想，你知道吗，让我们和专家聊聊。我觉得二十多岁的人，甚至一般人，都会对他们在线看到的所有对话，或者他们可能从其他人那里听到的关于呼吸法力量的建议产生疑问。所以我们要讨论它实际上是什么，它是如何工作的，根据科学它是如何运作的，它如何能与更现代的实践和治疗方法齐头并进，以及它的传统和古老根源。当然，我们邀请了一位专家，她现在就在我们身边。你好，杰西卡，欢迎来到节目。
Can you quickly introduce yourself for the listeners? It's such an honor and a delight to be with you, Gemma, this topic of your podcast about people in their 20s and how they want to care for themselves and develop themselves and grow and be healthy and all of that is just so important for our whole planet, not just the individual. So it's an honor to be with you. So, yes, my name is Jessica, and I am the co-director of the Global Professional Breathwork Alliance. And we are the organization that sets the international standards, the gold standard for
你能为听众快速自我介绍一下吗？能够与你在一起真是我的荣幸和喜悦，杰玛，你关于二十多岁年轻人及其如何关爱自己、自我发展、成长和保持健康的播客主题，以及这一切，对我们的整个星球都非常重要，而不仅仅是个体。所以能和你在一起是我的荣幸。所以，是的，我叫杰西卡，我是全球专业呼吸法联盟（Global Professional Breathwork Alliance）的联合主任。我们是制定国际标准、金标准的组织，用于
breathwork training and ethics. And I also have the real privilege of being the director of Inspiration Consciousness School in Maryland in the United States. And it's really a school that is dedicated to people from age 16 to 96 or 106 who want to develop their capacity to be present to themselves and other people who want to develop their capacity. to love, to be honest with you, to be compassionate and kind, but also to be creative and strong and powerful and contributing to themselves and the life of the planet. And so it's just my honor. Our school uses many different modalities, but all of them are breast-centered because we feel that it's the universal medicine. Oh, I love that. That's so beautiful. And what a beautiful introduction. You are most certainly an expert and I actually got my hands on your book where you sent me a
呼吸法培训和道德规范。我也非常荣幸能担任美国马里兰州灵感意识学校（Inspiration Consciousness School）的主任。它确实是一所致力于16岁至96岁或106岁想要发展自己对自我及他人临在能力的人的学校，他们希望发展自己的能力去爱，老实说，去保持同情和善良，同时也去发挥创造力、变得坚强和有力量，为自己和地球的生命做出贡献。所以这只是我的荣幸。我们学校使用许多不同的模式，但所有这些模式都以呼吸为中心，因为我们觉得它是普世的药物。哦，我太喜欢了。太美了。多么美丽的介绍。你绝对是一位专家，我实际上拿到了你的书，你寄给我一本
copy and it is so wonderfully comprehensive and I feel like breathwork is really having a moment online, on the internet in self-help communities right now. How would you explain what breathwork is? And more specifically, what is the difference between breathwork and simply just deep breathing or meditation. Good questions. So breathwork is a spectrum of breathing practices, voluntary, breathing, conscious breathing in different ways that address everything from relaxation at one end and regulation to deep human potential at the other end of the spectrum, like who are we at the what are each of us capable of, what could we bring to the world? And in between, you have these other factors such as how it is that we can bring more awareness
副本，它是如此的全面精彩，我觉得呼吸法现在在网络上、互联网上、自助社区中确实备受瞩目。你会如何解释什么是呼吸法？更具体地说，呼吸法与单纯的深呼吸或冥想有什么区别？好问题。所以呼吸法是一个呼吸练习的光谱，自主呼吸、以不同方式进行的有意识呼吸，它涵盖了从一端的放松和调节，到光谱另一端的深层人类潜能，比如我们在本质上是谁，我们每个人都有能力做什么，我们能为世界带来什么？在这两者之间，还有其他因素，例如我们如何带来更多意识
to everything we're doing. Or we can go a step further and say, okay, if there's something that needs intervention, like a physical challenge, an illness, an emotional dysregulation, are there particular breathing practices that would target, so to speak, those specific things? And there's also breathing practices that are totally meant to develop human capabilities, human capacities, such as strength, compassion, focus, joy. And so then at the far end, of course, you go all the way to who am I at my essence. So the breathwork is really a spectrum of all of those practices.
到我们正在做的每一件事中。或者我们可以再进一步说，好吧，如果有需要干预的事情，比如身体挑战、疾病、情绪失调，是否有特定的呼吸练习可以“针对”那些具体的事情？还有一些呼吸练习完全旨在发展人类的能力，人类的潜能，例如力量、同情心、专注力、快乐。然后，当然，在光谱的另一端，你一直走到我在本质上是谁。所以呼吸法实际上是所有这些练习的光谱。
And what I would say is it's definitely differentiated from just straight meditation because a lot of meditation is centered on the breathing or uses the breathing, but there is an aspect of meditation that is about realizing sort of a more transcendent self, a more peaceful self, all of which is fantastic. I meditate too. I'm a great believer in it. Breathwork, though, is very focused on embodiment. It's focused on how do I experience these things in my body. And rather than trying to transcend certain human characteristics, shall we say, really the deeper kind of breathwork is about embracing all of those characteristics and finding out what's at the core of our behaviors, what's at the core of our motivations, why we do the wonderful things we do,
我要说的是，它绝对有别于单纯的冥想，因为很多冥想都以呼吸为中心或使用呼吸，但冥想有一个方面是关于实现某种更超越的自我，一个更平静的自我，所有这些都棒极了。我也冥想。我对它深信不疑。然而，呼吸法非常注重具身化（embodiment）。它关注的是我如何在我的身体中体验这些事情。而且，与其试图超越某些人类特征，不如说更深层次的呼吸法是关于拥抱所有这些特征，并找出我们行为的核心是什么，我们动机的核心是什么，为什么我们做那些美好的事情，
why we do the things that aren't so good for us and sabotage ourselves and others, and how we can actually transform those in the moment in the body. And so we do find that there are some studies that show that about 10% of people who meditate, it actually dysregulates them rather than regulates them because it's not dealing with some of the things that they may be carrying like trauma, for instance. Whereas with breathwork, particularly if you're being guided by a really well-trained breath worker
为什么我们做那些对我们不太好、破坏我们自己和他人生活的事情，以及我们如何在当下在身体中实际转化这些事情。因此，我们确实发现有些研究表明，大约10%冥想的人实际上会导致失调，而不是调节，因为它没有处理他们可能携带的一些东西，例如创伤。而在呼吸法中，特别是如果你在由一个真正训练有素的呼吸师指导时
who really knows the territory, you're actually able to deal with your trauma. That is integrated into your experience of what it is to become present. That is such a beautiful explanation. And it's so interesting that you said meditation can cause some people to become dysregulated because I actually heard from a listener the other day. And I've heard from a number of listeners who are like, I don't get the deal with meditation. I always feel worse afterwards. So as soon as you said that, I was like, oh, I know a lot of people can relate to that.
他真的很了解这个领域，你实际上能够处理你的创伤。这被整合到你对如何变得临在的体验中。这是一个非常美丽的解释。而且你说冥想会导致一些人失调，这太有趣了，因为我前几天确实从一位听众那里听到了。我也听过许多听众说：“我不懂冥想是怎么回事。我事后总是感觉更糟。”所以你一说这个，我就想，哦，我知道很多人对此深有同感。
Can you give us an insight into the traditional origins of breathwork and of this practice? because I feel like this is not a new thing. Definitely not a new thing because, of course, we've all been breathing since the very beginning. Exactly. And in fact, the whole planet breath. Really, if you could think of it as one breath because everything's involved in the oxygen cycle. Oxygen is the most abundant element on our planet, the third most abundant element in the universe. and not only humans and all non-human creatures and animals, but also the plants, the fungi, the mycelium, trees, the earth itself has oxygen in it, the waters, the air, the sources of heat.
你能为我们深入了解一下呼吸法的传统起源和这项实践吗？因为我觉得这并不是一件新鲜事。绝对不是一件新鲜事，因为当然，我们从一开始就一直在呼吸。确实如此。事实上，整个星球都在呼吸。真的，你可以把它想象成一口呼吸，因为一切都参与了氧气循环。氧气是我们星球上最丰富的元素，是宇宙中第三丰富的元素，不仅人类和所有非人类生物及动物，还有植物、真菌、菌丝体、树木、地球本身都有氧气，水、空气、热源。
Everything's participating in photosynthesis or in the oxygen cycle. So it's really a comprehensive and unifying, and really it, It has us have the realization of our essential interconnection with everything. So we actually find, and you might have seen this in my book, I think I have about 16 to 20 different places or origins or cultures, where it shows that from the very beginning of particular religions, spiritual past cultures, it was just really known that breathing is it. You know, breathing is the connection between wherever it is or whatever it is that we are before we come into the body and actually being here. And so many cultures spoke of it as, you know, the connection with God, the connection with source, the connection with creation, or even more powerfully that it is creation. It is the source.
万物都在参与光合作用或氧气循环。所以它确实是一个全面且统一的，并且它让我们意识到我们与万物本质上是相互联系的。所以我们实际上发现，你可能在我的书里看到了，我想我有大约16到20个不同的地方、起源或文化，这表明从特定宗教、精神过去文化的最初开始，人们就真的知道呼吸就是一切。你知道，呼吸就是我们来到身体之前所在的地方或任何东西与实际来到这里之间的联系。许多文化将其描述为，你知道的，与上帝的联系，与源头的联系，与造物的联系，甚至更有力地认为它就是造物。它就是源头。
It is God sort of moving through reality in our bodies. And so you find it coming from Japan and China and India and Africa, the African nations. There's breathwork way back there, Mesopotamia, just every religion that I could find, Judaism, Christianity, Buddhism, Hinduism, Taoism, they all have at the core of their mystical teachings that it is actually the breath that is the doorway to everything that we're looking for. which is amazing because I feel like as much as it's just entering perhaps the brains and the minds of a new generation, it's being introduced to a younger group, the fact that it's been around for ages. It's kind of a lot of evidence in itself how magnificent it is.
它是上帝在我们的身体中穿梭于现实。所以你会发现它来自中国、日本、印度、非洲，非洲国家。远在那个时候就有呼吸法了，美索不达米亚，我能找到的每一个宗教，犹太教、基督教、佛教、印度教、道教，它们的神秘教义核心都有：实际上呼吸才是我们所寻找的一切的大门。这太棒了，因为我觉得尽管它可能刚刚进入新一代的大脑和思想，被介绍给更年轻的群体，但它已经存在了很久的事实，本身就是它有多么宏伟的许多证据。
But speaking of evidence, I'm sure a lot of people perhaps are listening to some of these explanations and being like, that sounds a bit niche. That sounds a bit perhaps woo-woo and whatever else they want to label it. There is definitely science behind this, as I saw in your book. Can you explain the science, any psychology, any studies that kind of support the benefits of breathwork? Yes, absolutely. I mean, it really is, Jemma, that modern science and ancient wisdom about breathing are finding each other. Modern science, in a sense, is catching up, you know, with ancient wisdom.
但说到证据，我确信很多人可能在听其中一些解释时会觉得：“听起来有点小众。听起来可能有点虚无缥缈（woo-woo），或者无论他们想贴上什么标签。”正如我在你的书中看到的，这背后绝对有科学依据。你能解释一下科学、任何心理学、任何支持呼吸法益处的某种研究吗？是的，绝对可以。我的意思是，杰玛，现代科学和关于呼吸的古老智慧正在彼此相遇。从某种意义上说，现代科学正在赶上古老智慧，
and it used to be that it might take, you know, you might find a study about breathing and its effects on the psyche maybe once a year, once every few years, you know, and now it's like the research is just coming out. I mean, breathwork, as you said, is really having its time, and I think it will remain that case because breathwork and breathing is the fundamental medicine and nutrient and friend of every human being. And it's also the unifying language of the human species. And we can talk about that later, how it transcends language and gender and political orientation and all of that. So the science, though, is really powerful at this point. It's irrefutable, for instance, that breathing is psychophysiological. And that means that literally every breath
过去，可能每隔一年、每隔几年才会找到一项关于呼吸及其对心理影响的研究，你知道的，现在研究就像井喷一样涌现。我的意思是，正如你所说，呼吸法确实迎来了它的时代，我认为这种情况会继续保持下去，因为呼吸法和呼吸是每个人的根本药物、营养素和朋友。它也是人类的统一语言。我们以后可以讨论它是如何超越语言、性别和政治倾向等等的。不过，此时此刻，科学确实非常有力量。例如，呼吸是心理生理的，这是无可辩驳的。这意味着从字面上看，每一次呼吸
we take has a psychological derivation and it has a physiological derivation and every breath that we take also affects us physically and affects us psychologically. So that science is irrefutable. Another piece of the science that's irrefutable is that slow, deep breathing stimulates the autonomic nervous system, which we want to have in balance where sympathetic and and parasympathetic are reflective. And when they're optimized, we're able to use our parasympathetic ability to rest and digest and be and be more peaceful when it's needed. And we're able to flow easily into the sympathetic mode when we need to be active,
我们采取的行动都有心理渊源，也有生理渊源，我们采取的每一次呼吸也会在生理和心理上影响我们。所以这门科学是无可辩驳的。科学的另一个无可辩驳的部分是，缓慢、深沉的呼吸会刺激自主神经系统，我们希望它保持平衡，其中交感神经和副交感神经是相互映射的。当它们得到优化时，我们能够利用我们的副交感神经能力来休息、消化、存在，并在需要时更加平静。当我们需要活跃时，我们能够轻松地进入交感神经模式，
when we need to respond to something, when there's something either urgent or just needful. And the flow back and forth between those two things ideally should be very very, very easy and it shouldn't be like, oh, it's hard for me to get going or I'm scared to get going or it's hard for me to stop when I'm frenetic and I can't really calm down. Optimal heart rate variability is the ability to move back and forth. So we've seen in study after study that breathing slowly with awareness helps to bring that that parasympathetic sympathetic balance so that you really have more. flow in your life. Another thing that's irrefutable is that some breathing, although I can be very
当我们对某事做出反应时，当有事情很紧急或仅仅是需要时。这两者之间的来回流动理想情况下应该非常、非常容易，而不应该表现为：“哦，我很难开始”或者“我害怕开始”，或者“当我狂热时我很难停下来，我无法真正平静下来”。最佳的心率变异性是来回移动的能力。所以我们在一个又一个的研究中看到，带着觉知缓慢呼吸有助于带来副交感神经与交感神经的平衡，这样你生活中就会有更多的流动。另一件无可辩驳的事情是，某些呼吸，虽然我可以对此非常
specific about this, it's not just any breathing. And it's not the same for every person. I think that's very important in breath work. I think a lot of people want there to be a formula. Like if I do this breathing, my anxiety will go down. If I do this breathing, I'll get more energy. But the reality is we all have a different genetics. We all have, you know, there's a lot of, lot of similarity, but there's also differences. We all have a different attachment history, meaning who were our caregivers and how do we relate to them and how does that affect the way our body feels and the way our breathing is. Our breathing does reflect our psychological state. And so it's just the case that there's going to be an indif, so two people that have anxiety
具体，不是随便什么呼吸都可以。而且对每个人来说都不是一样的。我认为这在呼吸法中非常重要。我认为很多人希望有一个公式。比如如果我做这种呼吸，我的焦虑就会减轻。如果我做这种呼吸，我就会获得更多精力。但现实是，我们都有不同的基因。我们都有，你知道，有很多很多的相似之处，但也有不同。我们都有不同的依恋历史，这意味着谁是我们的照顾者，我们如何与他们建立联系，这如何影响我们身体的感觉以及我们的呼吸方式。我们的呼吸确实反映了我们的心理状态。所以情况就是会存在差异，所以两个焦虑的人
may respond differently to different breathing techniques or different breathing practices. And this is why I think the ultimate breathwork evolution is going to be a bio-individualized coaching for each person that each person can then feel from within themselves what really regulates. But nevertheless, the majority of people will, with certain kinds of breathing, have their cortisol levels greatly reduced, their anxiety, levels go down. And there have been many studies showing different kinds of breathing, elevating mood. One study that came out of Stanford about a year and a half ago, almost two years ago, now that was Spiegel Huberman et al, showed that the most effective breathing, again, this is on a
可能会对不同的呼吸技巧或呼吸练习做出不同的反应。这就是为什么我认为呼吸法的终极演变将是针对每个人的生物个体化教练，每个人都可以从内心深处感受到真正能调节自己的方式。尽管如此，对于大多数人来说，通过特定种类的呼吸，他们的皮质醇水平会显著降低，焦虑水平也会下降。并且有许多研究表明，不同种类的呼吸可以提升情绪。大约一年半前，差不多两年前，斯坦福大学发表了一项研究，现在也就是Spiegel、Huberman等人参与的那项研究表明，最有效的呼吸方式——再次说明，这符合
bell curve. So for most people, but not everybody. For reducing anxiety and elevating mood is breathing in, and then before you breathe out, you take another little sip in. So you kind of lengthen that inhale in two segments, and then you sigh it out. And five minutes of that will create a state change. And if you practice it every day for 28, 30, 20 to 30 days for five minutes, then you get state to trait. You know, you get that movement from, I can, I know what this feels like now, to it's actually sticking with me. So that was a really interesting study because they were comparing that to, I think, box breathing and also cyclical hyperventilation.
钟形曲线，所以适用于大多数人，但不适用于所有人。为了减少焦虑和提升情绪，方法是吸气，然后在呼气之前，再小小地吸一口气。也就是说，你分两段拉长吸气过程，然后将其叹出。这样做五分钟就会产生状态的改变。如果你每天练习五分钟，持续28天、30天、20到30天，那么你就会从“状态”过渡到“特质”。你知道的，你会从“我现在知道这种感觉是什么了”这种体验，转变成它真正留存并固化在你身上。所以这是一个非常有趣的研究，因为他们当时是在将其与，我记得还有盒式呼吸以及循环过度通气进行对比。
So, you know, different breathing techniques can address different aspects of our psychological states and how we can come into greater regulation, but also how we can deal with the unmet parts of ourselves. know, perhaps it's like the parts of ourselves that didn't get nourished or nurtured enough when we were children. So these are the kinds of things that can happen when you're working with the psychological material that we do in therapy, which is really powerful. I'm not saying we shouldn't be doing therapy. I'm actually making a proposal that the beauty of therapeutic understanding is going to be activated and enhanced by bringing breathwork into it because we're able to go underneath the verbal defenses, the orientations, the descriptions that we make
所以，你知道，不同的呼吸技巧可以解决我们心理状态的不同方面，以及我们如何能够达到更高水平的调节，还有我们如何处理自身未被满足的部分。你知道，也许这就像是我们内在那些在童年时期没有得到足够滋养或培育的部分。所以，当你运用我们在治疗中使用的那些心理素材时，就会发生这些类型的事情，这真的非常强大。我并不是说我们不应该做心理治疗。我实际上是在提出这样一个观点：通过将呼吸法引入其中，治疗性理解的美妙之处将被激活并得到增强，因为我们能够穿透那些言语防御、导向，以及我们所做的各种描述
about ourselves and others, and we're able to get to feelings that we weren't able to get to. We're able to get to capacities that might be lying dormant in us that never got the nutrients and the attention that they need. There's all kinds of possibilities, and that includes expanded states of consciousness. That's such a beautiful explanation. I feel like you've mentioned some of the different techniques a couple of times. You mentioned box breathing. Then there was that inhale.
关于我们自己和他人，我们能够触及那些以往无法触及的情感。我们能够激发出可能潜藏在我们体内、从未获得所需营养和关注的潜能。这里面有各种各样的可能性，其中也包括扩展的意识状态。这真的是一个非常美妙的解释。我觉得你之前已经好几次提到过一些不同的技巧。你提到了盒式呼吸。然后就是那种吸气方式。
What are some of the most, obviously, see, I don't know the names. What are some of the different types of breathwork techniques? How do they kind of work? And what are they meant to be targeted? Like, are there a couple that are the major pillars of breathwork? What are the most, like, common ones? So that's a really good question, Jemma. As you may know from the book, I've really looked at the breathwork spectrum,
那么，最……显然你看，我不知道这些名字。不同类型的呼吸技巧有哪些？它们是如何发挥作用的？它们的针对目标是什么？比如说，有没有哪几种是呼吸法的主要支柱？最常见的有哪些？这是一个非常好的问题，杰玛。正如你可能从书中了解到的那样，我实际上研究了呼吸法谱系，
and I've identified five sort of groupings of breathwork. So the first grouping is rest and relaxation or restoration or regulation. And those are your simple reading techniques. There's so many of them where it's just breathing in, inhaling a little deeper than normal usually, and then kind of sighing it out or letting it out or groaning it out. You know, it's wonderful to watch children do this, you know, when they're kind of angry, and then they take three deep breaths and they let it out. And then they go, I was angry at Johnny.
并将呼吸法大致归纳为五类。因此，第一类是休息与放松，或者说恢复与调节。这些都是简单的呼吸技巧。这类技巧有很多，比如吸气，通常比平时吸得深一点，然后将其叹出、呼出或呻吟着释放出来。你知道，看着孩子们这样做是一件很奇妙的事，你知道的，当他们有点生气时，他们会做三次深呼吸然后释放出来。接着他们会说：“我刚才生强尼的气了。”
And then I took three deep breasts and I'm not angry anymore of the regulation. So it can be as simple as anybody can do it. Just breathe a little deeper than normal and then let go. Just kind of let go, kind of a sigh, a release, or even you can, like I said, moan or groan or even make a sound. And there's other ones too. Things like it might be like a wave where you feel like there's the inhale coming in and there's the exhale going out. And these things will tend to give, put a kind of. of pause on whatever stressor has been happening, whatever stress reaction you're having,
“然后我做了三次深呼吸，我现在不生气了。”这就是调节。所以它可以很简单，任何人都能做到。只需比平时稍微深吸一口气，然后放手。只需顺其自然地释放、叹气，甚至像我说的，发出呻吟、叹息，或者甚至发出声音。还有其他类型的呼吸。比如像波浪一样的感觉，你感觉吸气涌入，呼气涌出。这些方法往往会给任何正在发生的压力源、任何你正在经历的压力反应按下暂停键，
and it will allow the body to find an equilibrium again. A second group has to do with awareness, and that's really the beginning of being more present. So that's where you're going to find your mindfulness techniques, your breath awareness techniques. And so actually there's a scientist at UCLA named Jack Feldman. He's a very awarded, considered really the top breeding scientist in the world today and has a prize that's like one step down from the Nobel. And he found the origin of breathing in the brainstem, which he named the pre-Botsinger complex. And he wanted, he was very interested about what is it, why is it that
并允许身体重新找到平衡。第二组与觉察有关，这实际上是变得更加当下的开始。所以在这里你会找到你的正念技巧、呼吸觉察技巧。事实上，加州大学洛杉矶分校有一位科学家名叫杰克·费尔德曼。他是一位屡获殊荣、被公认为当今世界顶尖的呼吸科学家，曾获得仅次于诺贝尔奖的奖项。他在脑干中找到了呼吸的源头，并将其命名为前博岑格复合体。他当时想要探究，他也对以下问题非常感兴趣：为什么
mindfulness works for most people. And what he discovered was that when it works, the reason it's working has to do with breathing. The mindfulness, it's not so much about what you're paying attention to or that helps. It's an enhancement. But he took mice and he breathed to them. He made them breathe at a certain rate for a certain amount of time each day. And the group that did that breathing 30 days later, when they were introduced to a fear-inducing stimulus, they were markedly less fearful than the control group. So it's things like that where he hasn't quite published that study yet, but it's going to be coming out. So you have these breath awareness, mindfulness techniques that really give you the capacity to be more aware of your
正念对大多数人有效。而他发现的是，当它起作用时，其原因与呼吸有关。正念，与其说取决于你把注意力放在哪里（当然这有帮助，算是一种提升），不如说它源于呼吸。他拿老鼠做实验，让它们每天在特定时间内以特定速率呼吸。30天后，进行过这种呼吸的那组老鼠在接触到诱发恐惧的刺激时，显着比对照组不那么害怕。所以就是这样的一些事情，虽然他还没有完全发表那项研究，但它即将问世。所以你拥有这些呼吸觉察、正念技巧，它们真正赋予了你觉察自身的能力。
internal environment, your interception, and your extroception, like what is going on around you, and to be in the present rather than in the future or the past only. Your third grouping has to do with interventions. So this is where, you know, you have asthma, you have hyperactivity, neurodivergence, you have a kind of a low energy, like you constantly sort of feel fatigued. You have a hyperactivity and you feel over-adrenalized. Yeah, there are just things like that. And there are very specific techniques that can address those kinds of things. For instance, one is something that I learned when I was much younger and I was studying yogic breathing techniques, yoga pranium, is sleeping, a sleeping breathing technique.
内在环境、内感受和外感受，比如了解你周围正在发生的事情，并且活在当下，而不是仅仅停留在未来或过去。你的第三组与干预有关。所以在这里，你知道，如果你有哮喘、多动症、神经发散特征，或者你有一种低能量状态，比如你经常感到疲劳。或者你有过度活跃且肾上腺素过高的情况。是的，就是诸如此类的问题。有一些非常具体的技巧可以解决这些问题。例如，其中一种是我在很小的时候学习瑜伽呼吸法、瑜伽调息时学到的，那是一种睡眠呼吸法。
And really works. It has to do with the ratio of the inhale to the exhale. Or there's another one that I talk about in the book that I was taught it as asthma breathing or asthma chronyama, but I've renamed it respiratory healing because it just works on about any kind of respiratory ailment, emphysema, COPD. My own father had COPD, and I had him doing these exercises. And he lived to be 99. and the doctor said that there was no doubt that the breathing techniques had really given him extra time, extra years. You know, so you'll have also techniques in there for deep emotional regulation, like coherent breathing, which is sometimes called resonance breathing, which is basically an equivalent ratio of the inhale and the exhale are the same count.
而且确实很管用。它与吸气和呼气的比例有关。或者书中提到的另一种，别人教我时称之为哮喘呼吸或哮喘调息法，但我将其重新命名为呼吸疗愈，因为它几乎对任何种类的呼吸系统疾病都有效，比如肺气肿、慢阻肺。我自己的父亲就患有慢阻肺，我让他做这些练习。他活到了99岁，医生说毫无疑问，这些呼吸技巧确实给了他额外的时间，多活了好几年。你知道的，其中也会包含一些用于深度情绪调节的技巧，比如相干呼吸，有时也被称为共振呼吸，这基本上是一种等比例呼吸，即吸气和呼气的时长计数是相同的，
and it's generally five to six breaths per minute for most people. But again, there's a bio-individuation and there are people that do better with four breaths a minute and there are people that do better with eight. And what the science is showing is actually just that it's the fact that the inhale and the exhale are at the same equivalent amount of time that is really the mitigating fact there. The fourth grouping has to do with human development. And these are your beautiful breathing techniques, like how do you breathe with the sense of breathing into your heart and feeling compassion, for instance, for yourself and others, and then letting your body feel. Or what kind of breathing can you do to feel more focused and stronger?
对大多数人来说，通常是每分钟呼吸五到六次。但同样地，这里存在生物个体差异，有些人每分钟呼吸四次效果更好，而有些人则适合每分钟八次。科学研究表明，实际上真正起到调节作用的关键因素，正是吸气和呼气持续的时间是完全相等的。第四组与人类发展有关。这些是美丽的呼吸技巧，比如你如何带着将气息吸入心脏并感受同理心（例如对自我和他人）的感觉去呼吸，然后让你的身体去感受。或者你可以做什么样的呼吸来感到更有专注力和力量？
Or what kind of breathing can you do to feel a sense of joy and gratitude and ebulence? So these are the development of the deeper kind of desirable human qualities. And then that fifth group is what I call human potential breathwork. And it's really where you're breathing in a certain way continuously. Some schools call it conscious connected breathing. There are so many different ways that this variety of breathing is called holotropic breathwork, integrative breathwork, rebirthing, conscious connected breathing, therapeutic breath work, transformational breath.
或者你可以做什么样的呼吸来感受到喜悦、感恩和热情？这些都是更深层次、更理想的人类品质的发展。然后第五组就是我所说的人类潜能呼吸法。这实际上是指你以某种特定方式进行持续呼吸。有些流派称之为觉知连接呼吸。这种多样化的呼吸有许多不同的称呼，如 holotropic breathwork（全息呼吸）、整合呼吸、觉醒呼吸、觉知连接呼吸、治疗性呼吸、变革呼吸。
And all of them are giving the person permission to breathe really deeply and really continuously, because when we hold our breath, there's a kind of unconsciousness that can happen. So you breathe continuously so that the unconscious starts to become more conscious. It's really quite miraculous. and that feelings, images, yearnings, hopes, you know, even the so-called visions that we can all have can begin to surface in an atmosphere of love, in an atmosphere of unconditional, positive regard and acceptance. And we can integrate these more transcendental, more transpersonal, more holotropic aspects of ourself. Really, it's the level of soul in some ways. It's really that part of the
所有这些都在允许一个人进行真正深沉且持续的呼吸，因为当我们屏住呼吸时，可能会产生一种无意识状态。因此，你需要持续呼吸，以便潜意识开始变得更有意识。这真的是相当神奇的。情感、意象、渴望、希望，甚至是我们所有人都能拥有的所谓愿景，都可以在爱的氛围中、在无条件积极关注和接纳的氛围中浮现出来。我们可以整合我们身上这些更具超越性、更具超个人特质、更具全息呼吸特质的方面。真的，从某些方面来看，这是灵魂层面的体现。这确实是那种属于……的部分：
psyche that wonders about the deeper parts of life and the mystery of life. Like, what is this all really about and who am I really? And what am I really capable of? And what is the meaning of life? And so that kind of breathwork does that. And so there are many different techniques. There's a variety of techniques, shall we say, a whole panoply. And I feel like, there's something for everyone. Perhaps one of the misconceptions with breath work is that, yes, like we said before, it is just deep breathing and there is one strategy. But like you said, breath is like life itself. And if life itself is as varied as it is, then our breath can be as well. We are going to take a short break right now. But when we return, I want to also
心灵会去思考生命的更深层部分以及生命的奥秘。比如，这一切到底是为了什么？我到底是谁？我到底能发挥什么潜能？生命的意义是什么？这种呼吸法就能做到这一点。所以有许多不同的技巧。可以说有各种各样的技巧，包罗万象。我觉得，每个人都能从中找到适合自己的。也许对呼吸法的一个误解是，正如我们之前所说的那样，它只深呼吸并且只有一种策略。但正如你所说，呼吸就像生命本身。如果生命本身如此丰富多彩，那么我们的呼吸也可以如此。我们现在要进行短暂的休息。但当我们回来时，我还想探讨
talk about some of the misconceptions about breathwork, whether it can be scary, what you would say to skeptics, but also how we can kind of integrate it into more modern medicinal practices and modern therapeutic techniques. So stay with us. Two percent. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more, to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry.
关于呼吸法的某些误解，比如它是否会让人感到害怕，你对怀疑论者有什么想说的，以及我们如何将其融入更多现代医学实践和现代现代化治疗技术中。所以请继续收听我们节目。百分之二。这就是当有自动扶梯可用时，仍然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客节目《2%》中，我将剖析精神坚韧度、体能训练的科学，以及在我们这个奇特现代世界中培养韧性的方法。我将与作家、研究人员以及其他健康和健身专家等展开对话，带大家看透那些主导健康产业的、不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。
We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO percent on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tap Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people.
我们曾经真的相信植物油本质上会引发炎症。我们错了。我们在世界上感到恐慌的许多问题都是压力造成的。让自己经历一些磨难，你就会在经历之后成为一个更快乐、更满足、更健康的人。收听《2%》。这就是在IHeart Radio应用程序、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方播出的《TWO percent》。你还记得黛安娜·罗斯在VMA颁奖典礼上双击小肯姆的胸部吗？或者当坎耶说乔治·布什不喜欢黑人时？
I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do with Little Kim? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick it here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill waxing all about crack in the 80s.
我知道你在想什么。乔治·布什跟小肯姆到底有什么关系？好吧，你可以在《回顾过去》播客中找到答案。我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利士。每一集，我们都会挑选一个事件，剖析事情的始末，并试着理解我们是如何挺过那段时光的。其中包括最近的一集，马克兰蒙特·希尔大谈80年代的快克可卡因。
To be clear, 84 is big to me, not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack all day, but just so y'all know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack, so I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now, so... Thank you for finishing that sentence. Yes, I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really?
坦白说，84年对我来说意义重大，不仅仅是因为快克。我随时都能聊一聊快克，但只是让大家知道而已。我的意思是，马克兰，这是我们讨论快克的第二集了，所以我开始看出这里面有一条主线了。我们现在还在讨论艾滋病，所以……谢谢你把那句话说完。是的，我不认为对黑人来说还有比这更重要的一年了。真的吗？
Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years. from black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hardway with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games. And in recognition of Mental Health Awareness Month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own
是的。对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人而言最重要的年份之一。在IHeart Radio应用程序、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《回顾过去》。欢迎来到我的新播客《迎难而上》，我是主持人、你最喜欢的治疗师基尔·盖恩斯。为了庆祝心理健康意识月，我带来了我自己在心理健康领域十多年的
experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking, Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that We don't realize that we are in possession of the thing. And we're still chasing it. And we don't know when we've done enough. Because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses.
经验，并与许多不可思议的嘉宾进行了对话。我说的是特里普·方丹、瑞安·克拉克。有时我们在追求某样东西时，会太过于深陷于追逐的过程中，以至于我们没有意识到我们其实已经拥有了那样东西。而我们却还在继续追逐它。我们不知道什么时候才算足够。因为人们总是盯着记分牌。生活变成了一场关于输赢的较量。
Steve Burns, Dustin Ross, because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth? Are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Kear Gaines, is we have real conversations about healing, growth,
史蒂夫·伯恩斯，达斯汀·罗斯，因为你觉得在人间做一个好人很重要吗？你做一个好人是因为你害怕吗？因为那是两种不同的动机，兄弟。绝对是的。那是两个不同层面的信任。我希望你能够真正地做一个好人。和我基尔·盖恩斯一起，在我的新播客《迎难而上》中，就疗愈、成长、
fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, Learn the Hardway. Open your free iHeartRadio app. Search Learn the Hardway and listen now. In 2023, former Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story. This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice in someone's, correct?
为人父、压力和人生目标展开真实的对话。打开你免费的iHeartRadio应用程序。搜索《迎难而上》并立即收听。2023年，前《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德发现自己卷入了一场亲子鉴定丑闻。随后的家事法庭听证会暴露出她故事中明显的矛盾之处。这引发了一场长达数年的法庭之战来证明真相。你曾多次篡改过这份特定的检测报告，对吗？
I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for. Sunlight's the greatest disinfected. They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Gregalespian and Michael Marincini. My mind was blown.
我篡改过一次检测。这动用了大批互联网侦探才破了案。我希望人们能够看到他们的纳税被用在了哪里。阳光是最好的消毒剂。他们会发现一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男性。格雷格·莱斯皮安和迈克尔·马里奇尼。我的脑子彻底炸裂了。
I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news. that Ameriopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over until justice is served in Arizona. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the Iheart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《情网》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节季的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面对了后果。女士们先生们，突发新闻。马里科帕县宣布劳拉·欧文斯已被指控犯有欺诈罪。在亚利桑那州正义得到伸张之前，这一切都不会结束。在Iheart Radio应用程序、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《情网》播客。
Okay, we are back with our breathwork expert, Jessica. So this is a personal question of mine that I have about breathwork. I'm basically using this interview as an excuse just to ask you what I want to know. which is can breathwork be scary? You know, some people report feeling strange afterwards or even high or whatever it is. Yeah, can it be scary? What should we know about that element of it? So I think most people enjoy feeling high and because it's a positive experience.
好的，欢迎回来，我们的呼吸法专家杰西卡。所以这是我关于呼吸法的一个私人问题。我基本上是借这次采访为借口来问我想知道的事情。也就是，呼吸法会吓人吗？你知道，有些人报告说事后感觉很奇怪，甚至有嗨的感觉之类的。是的，它会吓人吗？关于它的那个部分，我们应该知道些什么？所以我想大多数人喜欢这种嗨的感觉，因为这是一种积极的体验。
So that part alone isn't what scares them. What scares them is when there is what I will call intracycic material, feelings that may have been buried, memories that may have not, you know, you didn't remember that you knew these things, capacities within the self, even like transpersonal kinds of experiences, like feeling connected to everything, feeling that there's a power greater than yourself, whether you just think of that as physics, like, you know, quantum. quantum field or whether you think of it as a divine entity, I think that in enough itself, that wouldn't scare anybody because it actually feels like you're coming more home to yourself than you've ever been. But what scares people is that they don't, they didn't live in a culture that taught them that it was okay to have those kind of experiences. So if they're not working with a breath worker who's really skilled when they're going into those deeper kinds of experiences, they might have a moment of feeling un-mirrered.
所以仅仅是那部分并不会吓到他们。真正让他们害怕的是，当出现我所谓的“内部循环材料”时，那些可能被埋藏的感觉，你可能没有记住的记忆（你知道的，你并不记得你知道这些事），内在的潜能，甚至是超个人式的体验，比如感觉自己与一切万物相连，感觉到存在着某种比你自身更伟大的力量，无论你只是把它当成物理学，比如量子场论，还是把它当成某种神圣的实体，我认为仅凭这一点本身，是不会吓到任何人的，因为实际上它会让你感觉比以往任何时候都更加回归自我。但真正吓到人们的是，他们并没有、他们没有生活在一个教会他们可以拥有那种体验的文化中。因此，如果他们在进入那种更深层的体验时，没有与真正熟练的呼吸法治疗师合作，他们可能会有一刻感到“没有被镜像反映”的感觉。
You know, psychotherapeutically, we want people in process to feel mirrored, to feel attuned to. And so this is why I feel really lucky, privileged, honored to be the co-director of the Global Professional Breathwork Alliance, because we are setting standards for training. and for ethics. And we have a very deep ethics around the expanded states of consciousness that people can access through breathing. You know, there's been two studies now that have shown that that kind of group five breathwork, that human potential breathwork, can be equivalent or even greater than the effects of
你知道，在心理治疗中，我们希望身处过程中的人能够被镜像映照，被感同身受。所以这就是为什么我觉得自己非常幸运、荣幸、备受尊崇，能够担任全球专业呼吸法联盟（Global Professional Breathwork Alliance）的联合主任，因为我们正在为培训和职业道德设定标准。而且我们在人们通过呼吸可以进入的扩展意识状态方面，有着非常深厚的道德伦理。你知道，现在已经有两项研究表明，那种集体五阶段呼吸法，那种人类潜能呼吸法，其效果可以等同于甚至大于迷幻药的效果，但却没有副作用。
psychedelics, but without the side effects. But what you need for it to be of ultimate use is you need. is you need a guide or a coach or an understanding of what's happening so that you can celebrate that this incredible thing is opening up for you. So I know, like, for instance, yes, occasionally one example would be if you're doing that deeper kind of breathwork, you might feel a kind of tingling, for instance, in your hands or feet or just anywhere in your body. And you come to understand that at the deepest level,
但要让它发挥出终极的作用，你需要的是什么？你需要的是一名向导或教练，或者对正在发生的事情有所理解，这样你就可以庆祝这种令人难以置信的事物正在为你敞开。所以我知道，比如说，是的，偶尔有一个例子就是，如果你在做那种更深层的呼吸法，你可能会感觉到一种刺痛感，比如在你的手、脚或身体的任何地方。然后你就会逐渐明白，在最深的层面上，
It's where there's life force waking up that hasn't been there before. But if you don't have somebody explaining that to you, it could be, it could feel scary for sure. But I remember, for instance, one student I had that when it stopped happening for him, because he just got to the place where he was living it in an integrated way all the time, he was kind of sad because he liked that, you know, that feeling of being stretched a little bit. So I don't think that breathwork needs to be scary at all. And I think that in our school, for instance, at Inspiration Consciousness School, I think our practitioners are trained to track people.
那是生命力在苏醒，一种以前从未有过的生命力。但如果你没有人在向你解释这一点，那肯定会让人感到害怕。但我记得，例如我曾有一个学生，当这种感觉对不再发生在他身上时，因为他已经达到了这样一种境界：他时刻都在以一种整合的方式生活着，他甚至有点难过了，因为他喜欢那种感觉——那种被稍微拉伸一点的感觉。所以我觉得呼吸法根本不需要吓人。而且我认为在我们学校，比如灵感意识学校（Inspiration Consciousness School），我认为我们的从业者都经过训练，能够追踪和关注人们的状态。
We don't actually like people to do group breathwork without also doing some individual breathwork where they're getting that one-on-one coaching. And we tell them that this is something you'll be able to do on your own very shortly, but you just want to become familiar with the kind of territory that can open up, because you are, you know, you are filled with potential and all of us is going to come forward. It sounds like it's quite a smart approach, one that keeps people safe and one that keeps people in the space that they're prepared and ready to be in, which I think makes me feel a lot better about this practice. A kind of follow-up question to that as well is, what are some of the breakthroughs that people experience? I know you've spoken a bit about
实际上，我们不喜欢人们在没有进行一些一对一教练指导的个人呼吸法的情况下盲目进行集体呼吸法。我们会告诉他们，这是你很快就能独自完成的事情，但你只是需要先熟悉一下可能会展开的领域，因为你充满了潜能，而我们所有的一切都将显现出来。听起来这是一种非常聪明的做法，既能保障人们的安全，又能让人们保持在他们已经做好准备的空间里，这让我对这项实践感觉好多了。对此的一个后续问题是，人们会经历哪些突破呢？我知道你之前谈到过一些你学生经历的突破，也有你自己的。是的，人们大概可以期待什么或者不期待什么？
some from students of yours and also some of your own. Yeah, what can people kind of maybe expect or not expect? So first of all, I mean, some of it depends on what level of breathwork you're engaging, right? So if you're just, if you're doing group one practices, you're mostly going to feel a sense of regulation, release, relaxation, let go, you know, just more at ease, less, adrenalized, less cortisol going, and that's wonderful. That's beautiful. Or if you're doing your mindfulness stuff, you'll feel more present, more engaged, more able to be with whatever it is, whether it's cold or hot or busy or not busy or whatever. And then there's your individual techniques that are targeting those particular conditions. And there's the development of
所以首先，我的意思是，这在某种程度上取决于你正在参与哪个级别的呼吸法，对吧？所以如果你只是在做一阶段的练习，你主要会感受到一种调节、释放、放松、放下的感觉，你知道的，就是更加轻松，肾上腺素分泌减少，皮质醇减少，这太棒了。这太美妙了。或者如果你在做正念相关的事情，你会感觉更当下、更投入，更能与当下的一切共处，无论是冷是热，是忙碌还是不忙碌，诸如此类。然后还有针对特定状况的个人专属技巧，以及对这些自我品质和潜能的开发。
these qualities of self and capacity that you might have. I think if we're doing the deeper kind of breathwork that we, that you're talking about with some of those effects, I could just tell a few stories. One person was a concentration camp survivor from Auschwitz, and her son wanted her to come see me because he had grown up. She had survived. Dowschewit, so she didn't want anything to happen to her children. So they were never allowed to like, flying trees or, you know, a mountain or anything that she thought could cause them damage. She was just like so fearful. So she had high anxiety levels, massive amounts of control issues. And she didn't want to come see me. She came and she said to me, the only reason I'm coming
如果你正在做我们刚才谈到的、会产生那些效果的更深层的呼吸法，我可以讲几个故事。其中一个人是奥斯威辛集中营的幸存者，她的儿子想让她来见我，因为他是看着她经历这些长大的。她虽然在奥斯威辛活了下来，所以她不希望自己的孩子们发生任何意外。因此他们从来不允许像坐飞机、爬树、爬山，或者任何她认为可能对他们造成伤害的事情。她就是充满了恐惧。所以她有很高的焦虑水平，有着大量的控制欲问题。她一开始不想来见我。她来的时候对我说，我来这里的唯一原因是为了安抚他。什么都不会发生的。她从未讲述过她在奥斯威辛的故事。她拒绝谈论此事。所有人——甚至是她的家人——所知道的只是她活了下来。所以她说，我不会告诉你任何事的。所以我坐在她身边，我们聊起了她的儿子。她说，好吧，我就在这里坐一个小时，然后我就会告诉他我来过了，我们就回家。所以当她说了一些关于她儿子的美好事情，表达了她真的很爱他，而且我也很爱她的儿子时，
is to appease him. Nothing's going to happen. She had never told her story about Auschwitz. She refused to talk about it. All anybody even her family knew was that she had survived it. So she said, I'm not going to tell you or anything. So I sat there with her and we would talk about her son. She said, well, just sit here for an hour and then I'll tell him I did it and we'll go home. So when she would say something beautiful about her son that she really loved it and I loved her son too,
我会说：“那太美妙了。哇，我能静静地感受一下吗？”然后我会深深地、清晰地吸一口气。过了一会儿，镜像神经元开始发挥作用了。于是，在她没有意识到的情况下，我从未要求她深呼吸。我不想打破她的控制。她有权保护自己，毕竟她经历了那样的人生。我想要尊重她内在的智慧。
I'd say, that's so beautiful. Wow, can I just take that in for a minute? And I would breathe deeply and audibly. And the mirror neurons started going after a while. And so without her realizing it, I never asked her to breathe deeply. I didn't want to break down her control. She had every right to be protective of herself with what she had lived through. I wanted to honor her internal wisdom.
所以我从未要求她深呼吸，但我会深呼吸。大约20分钟后，她自己都没有意识到，每当我深呼吸时，她也开始跟着深呼吸了。然后她请我分享一些我生活中的痛苦，当我讲到某些能唤起她同理心的事时，她在不知不觉中又深呼吸了。而我能告诉你的是，经历了足够多这样的深呼吸后，在大约进行了一个小时左右，她开始向我吐露心声。没有任何勉强，我甚至没有要求她，她向我讲述了她在奥斯威辛集中营幸存的整个故事。我们在那里待了两个小时。当她的儿子进来时，他说房间里简直散发着光芒。她变成了一个更有连接感的人。并且她培养出了勇气——当斯皮尔伯格带着“大屠杀”项目（即他准备拍摄《辛德勒的名单》时）来到小镇时，他在采访集中营幸存者。她有勇气去讲述自己的故事。
So I never asked her to breathe deeply, but I would breathe deeply. And after about 20 minutes, she didn't realize it, but she was starting to breathe deeply whenever I would. And then she asked me to share about some suffering in my life, and when I would say certain things that evoked compassion in her, she would breathe deeply without realizing it. And all I can tell you is that enough of those deep breaths happen that about an hour into it, she started sharing with me. With no, I didn't even ask her, she shared with me the whole story of how she survived Dauschwitz. And we were there for two hours. And when her son came in, he said the room was just luminous. She became a more connected person. And she developed the courage that when Stephen
而那个故事至今仍挂在他们的网站上。她的名字叫爱丽丝·克劳斯（Alice Krause）。所以这是一个非凡的故事，因为我们甚至没有做那种高强度的呼吸训练，它只是通过更深层的呼吸和镜像作用，你知道的，也就是卡尔·罗杰斯这位伟大的人本主义心理学家教导我们的“无条件积极关注”，以及通过共同呼吸如何能增强这种关注——这种关注超越了语言、种族、性别认同，你知道的，它将我们带到一个更加统一的境地，看看结果发生了什么。我想起了一个年轻的双相情感障碍患者，但他当时没有被确诊。他经历了一种灵性的觉醒。他真的只是看到了所有关于生命的更宏大的真理。但他的母亲也患有双相情感障碍，她注意到他开始变得有点躁狂。于是她带他来见我。对于处于那种状态的人，我们绝不会让他们做快速呼吸。所以我们做了非常缓慢、受调节的呼吸。在某个时刻我说，我认为你需要，我们应该去医院做个评估，看看你是否也可以通过一些药物治疗来获得帮助。于是我们去了大约六天，他也开始服用一些药物。然后我们花了大约两年的时间进行呼吸训练。
Spielberg came to town with the Shoah project, which was when he was going to make Schindler's list, he was interviewing concentration camp survivors. She had the courage to go and tell her story. And that story is still up on their website. Her name is Alice Krause. And so that's a remarkable story because we didn't even do that of intensive breathing. It was just the deeper breathing and the mirroring, you know, the unconditional positive regard that Carl Rogers, great humanist psychologist taught us about and how that can be enhanced by breathing together, which transcends language, race. gender orientation, you know, it brings us down to a more unified place and look what happened. I think about a young man who had bipolar disorder, but it was undiagnosed. And he had a kind of
顺着他的呼吸，他下定决心要停药，并能够在不陷入双相情感障碍状态的情况下，重新进入他曾经体验过的那种心流状态，以及他所称的“觉醒”。事实也的确如此。20年过去了，他在这期间再也没有吃过药。他过着美好的生活，并且一直在做呼吸练习。我的意思是，我可以一直说下去。杰玛，这真的是关键所在。我认为有一些这样的呼吸法练习，人们可以用来在日常生活中支持自己，让自己更健康，情绪调节得更好。我鼓励每个人每天至少进行7分钟的深呼吸。
spiritual awakening. And he was really just seen like all of these greater truths about life. But his mother, who did have bipolar, was noticing that he was getting kind of manic. And so she brought him to see me. And we would never do like fast breathing with somebody that was in that kind of state. So we did very slow regulated breathing. And at some point I said, I think that you need, we should go to the hospital and you should get evaluated to see if you could also be assisted with some, you know, pharmaceuticals. And so we went for like six days and he got onto some medication as well. And then it took us about two years of breathing. Following his breathing, he was determined to get off the medication and to be able to access those states that he had been in a flow and,
但如果你真的一直在寻找心理健康和完整性，包括那种与无意识自我发生转化的完整性，以及与我们体内可能受创伤的部分的和解（在这个时代的世界上，谁在某种程度上又没有受过创伤呢？），我认为与一位真正熟练的呼吸法治疗师建立联系，哪怕只是很短的一段时间，也能真正让你走上正确的道路。我喜欢这个建议。这差不多把我们带到了倒数第二个问题。我们现在快要结束这次采访了。
you know, awakening is what he called it, without going into the bipolar state. And indeed, that happened. And it's 20 years later, and he's not been on medication for that whole time. And he leads a wonderful life and he does breathing techniques. And I mean, I could go on and on. It's really, I think one of the keys, Gemma, there are these, I think that there are these kind of breathwork practices that people can do to just support themselves on a daily basis, to be healthier, to be more regulated. I encourage everybody to do a minimum of seven minutes of just deeper.
我可以聊上好久。但你其实已经谈到过了。你认为呼吸法如何融入更广泛的治疗实践、现代医学的更广泛需求以及诊断之中？是的，它如何能成为一种针对心理健康及困扰人们的更广泛病症的个性化方法的一部分，而又不会将自己标榜为唯一的选择？这就是我想表达的意思，作为一个补充选项。
breathing a day. But I think if you're really looking for psychological well-being and wholeness that includes that transformation that would happen with the unconscious self, with parts of us that might be traumatized and who isn't traumatized in today's world on one level, I think that developing a relationship with a really skilled breath worker, even for a short period of time, just really sets you on the right path. I love that advice. And that kind of brings me to our second last question. We're almost at the end of this interview now.
没错。它不是唯一的选项。它是一个可以以其他所有选项为核心的选项。所以，你知道，呼吸是通用的良药。即使是一个靠呼吸机维持生命的人，甚至是一个瘫痪的人也在呼吸。所以这是他们可以靠意志力去做的事情，即使他们在呼吸。我爸爸曾几次用过呼吸机，我们和他一起做过呼吸练习。你可以引导呼吸的意图性。
I could go on for ages. But you've kind of already talked about it. How do you think breathwork fits in with broader therapeutic practices, the broader need for modern day medicine, for diagnoses? Yeah, how can it be part of a more? individualized approach to mental health and broader conditions that kind of afflict people without offering itself as the only option. This is kind of what I'm trying to say, as an additive.
所以这确实是一种通用的良药，从它对人们对彼此有更大的包容和理解、并希望创造性地合作建立一个我们能共同享受的世界意味着什么的角度来看，这是一个非常令人兴奋的前景。因此，你知道，我有时会说的一句座右铭是：每个急诊室里都要有一位呼吸法治疗师，每个学校里都要有一位呼吸法治疗师，每个办公大楼里都要有一位呼吸法治疗师，每个剧院里都要有一位呼吸法治疗师。因为如果人们拥有能量感、身体健康感、情绪调节能力，并且在经历强烈情绪时能够得到回应，这确实可以极大地改善我们整个物种的健康状况。所以如果你考虑一些事情，例如，我曾与内在家庭系统疗法（Internal Family Systems）的创始人交谈过，我想很多听众可能都知道这个疗法。这是一个非常强大的心理学导向。我们讨论过这样一个事实：我曾与人们的“内在部分”共事过。这就是你思考的方式，好吧，有这样一个生气的内在部分。有这样一个消防员般的内在部分。有这样一个某某部分。它们每一个的呼吸方式都略有不同。但他们发现的是，它们的呼吸方式虽然略有不同，但它们都在呼吸。所以这就成了统一的要素。然后它们可以整合到“自体”之中。因此，我想不出有任何一种心理学流派，包括弗洛伊德分析法，其中深呼吸和拥有那种具身感不能帮助消除解离状态（这在心理治疗过程中非常重要），并且不能帮助带来能动感和个人赋权感。我想不出有任何一种针灸、灵气或身体工作等整体疗法，是不会从一个人能够通过呼吸来以躯体化的方式面对正在发生的事情中受益的。主流医学中也是如此。
Right. It's not the only option. It is an option that can be centered within every other option. So, you know, breathing's the universal medicine. Even a person on a respirator, even a person who's paralyzed is breathing. So there's something they can do volitionally, even if they're breathing. My dad was on a respirator a couple of times, and we did breathing practices with him. You can direct the intentionality of the breathing.
你知道，如果人们呼吸得更深，他们就会更健康。我父亲患有COPD。也就是慢性阻塞性肺疾病。就像我说的，医生们非常明确地表示，我们做的呼吸练习让他多活了好几年。所以我简直想不出有哪种疗法是它不能增强现有效果的，因为它有助于认知。它有助于提高觉察能力。当你进行有意识的呼吸时，大脑会发生什么变化？与仅仅激活脑干（我们在自动呼吸时只是从脑干获得激活）不同，当我们有意识地呼吸时，新皮层会被激活，
So it's really a universal medicine, and that's a very exciting prospect in terms of what it could mean for people having greater tolerance and understanding for each other. and wanting to work together creatively to build a world that we can all relish together. So I think that, you know, one of the mottos that I sometimes say is a breath worker in every emergency room, a breath worker in every school, a breath worker in every office building, a breath worker in every theater. because people having a sense of energy, physical well-being, emotional regulation, being responded to if they're having intense emotion, could really, really improve the health of our whole species. So if you think about something like, for instance, I've talked to the founder of internal family systems, which I think probably, a lot of your listeners know about it. It's a very powerful psychological orientation. And we've talked about the fact that I've worked with parts of people. That's how you think about, okay, there's this
边缘系统的大脑也会被激活。我们发现，呼吸回路贯穿于整个大脑。因此，你会在神经系统上建立一种全球性的连贯性，这使你能够获得更多的资源，让你保持在当下，而不是仅仅对事物进行无意识的反应。老实说，有意识呼吸的能力甚至能帮助我们对内感受以及我们自己身体内发生的事情有更强的感知，我认为这将成为医学、现代医学的一个绝佳合作伙伴，并且它能增强我们处于一个更加受调节状态的能力。我想我简直无法想出哪怕一种它不会起作用的疗法。就在你这么说的时候，我在脑子里拼命搜寻，然后我想，
part that's angry. There's this part that's a firefighter. There's this part. And each of them breathes a little differently. But what they find is that they breathe a little differently, but they're all breathing. So that becomes the unifying thing. And then they can integrate into the self. So I cannot think of a single psychological modality, including Freudian analysis, where breathing deeply and having that sense of embodiment helps to dissolve dissociation, which is a really important thing in psychological process, and helps bring the sense of agency and the sense of personal empowerment. I can't think of a single holistic modality of acupuncture or Reiki or, you know, the body works that wouldn't benefit by a person also being
不，我想不出任何一种。想不出任何一种。所以我这是在检验你的假设。所以我有最后一个问题要问你，它实际上与呼吸法毫无关系。事实上，我要求它与呼吸法没有任何关系。在我与每位嘉宾的每集节目结束时，我总是会问他们：对于一个20多岁的人，你会给出的最好的建议是什么？这个建议与我们今天谈论的内容完全无关。你知道，当你问出那个问题时，杰玛，我感到一股巨大的情绪——我要称之为“发光感”——在我体内升腾。因为老实说，我想说的是：你是如此美丽，你充满了潜能。无论你现在可能如何看待自己，
able to breathe to somatically meet whatever is happening. Same thing in mainstream medicine. You know, if people are breathing more deeply, they're healthier. My father had COPD. That's chronic obstructive pulmonary disease. And like I said, the doctors were very clear that the breathing that we did gave him several years of extra life. And so I just can't think of a single modality where it wouldn't enhance what's going on because it helps with document. It helps with awareness. And what happens in the brain when you take, when you consciously breathe, is rather than just activating, when we're breathing, we're just getting activation from the brain stem when we're automatically breathing. But when we breathe consciously, the neocortex comes online,
无论你可能认为自己的局限性是什么，或者你觉得有些东西是别人没有给你的——我的意思是，所有这些可能都是真的，但你内心深处有一个部分是神圣不可侵犯的、未受污染的、纯粹的美。我真的希望你能允许那些关心你、看到你的人去支持你，通过那些能激发你灵感的学习，允许你内在的这一部分显露出来，因为你是如此丰富。你将能够为这个星球贡献一些前人从未贡献过、后人也无法再次贡献的东西。你知道的，当你20多岁的时候——我想王尔德说过这样一句话：“青春是被年轻人挥霍的”。我不知道你是否听说过这个？哦，是的。当你20多岁的时候，依然有那么多自然的“气”（你知道的，自然的活力）。
and the limbic brain comes online. And we find that the respiratory circuits are embedded throughout the whole brain. So you develop a kind of global coherence neurologically, which gives you access to many more resources, keeps you more present instead of just reacting unconsciously to things. And so honestly, the ability for conscious breathing to help even us have a greater sense of interception and what's going on in our own body, I think would be a very partnering thing for medicine, for modern medicine, and just the ability to, yeah, to be in a more regulated state. I think I just have never been able to think of one modality where it wouldn't help. As you were saying that, I was trying to rack my brain and I was like,
即使你在应对慢性疾病，这也与你在70多岁时应对它有很大不同。因此，如果20多岁的人能够真正与他们内心深处的美丽、与蕴藏的潜能建立连接，真正相信它，并组成由相信他们、在他们一生中为他们加油呐喊的朋友和团队，20多岁的人拥有他们可以给予世界的一切。所以这将是我最深切的建议。我认为这是结束这一集的绝妙方式。这也是一个美好的提醒：对于任何正在收听节目录音的20多岁的人来说（这可能占了大多数人），我们真的是太年轻了。而且我总是非常感激，
no, I couldn't think of any. Couldn't think of any. So I'm testing your hypothesis there. So I've got one final question for you and it actually has nothing to do with breathwork. In fact, I ask that it doesn't have anything to do with breathwork. At the end of every episode I have with a guest, I always ask them, what is the best piece of advice that you would give to someone in their 20s that has nothing to do with what we, talked about today. You know, I feel a great deal of emotion and I'm going to call it luminosity rise up in me as you ask that question, Gemma. Because honestly, what I feel like I would say is you are so beautiful and you are so filled with potential. And whatever you may think about yourself
当我们邀请到许多富有智慧的人来到节目中，他们基本上都会说出类似的话，比如：放慢脚步，你还有时间，你会把事情搞清楚的。我觉得这有着难以置信的安慰作用。而且你所说的很多话都让我感到非常受益、滋养，并让我以一种不同的方式看待世界。所以我真的很感激你的智慧和知识。感谢你来到我们的节目。这是我的荣幸，杰玛。谢谢你为这个世界所做的工作。哦，当然。我会把杰西卡的所有链接放在下方，包括她书的链接、她学校的链接以及你能找到她的其他所有地方。如果你想继续了解呼吸法，她就是你的首选源泉。我想她对这个精彩话题的了解程度超过了99.999%的人。再次感谢大家的收听。如果你喜欢这一集，请务必把它分享给朋友或你认为会受益的人。同时也请确保在Instagram上关注我们（@That Psychology Podcast），这样你就能知道新节目何时上线、向我们提问、提供反馈或加入对话。但直到下一次，保重，保持善良。保持善良。对自己温柔一点。深呼吸，我们很快很快就会再聊。2%。
now, whatever you may think are your limitations or that you weren't given certain things, I mean, all of that may be true, but there is a part of you that is, you know, inviolately, I mean, untouched, just beauty within you. And I really hope that you will allow yourself to be supported by people who care about you and see you and by learning that stimulates you and that you will allow this part of you to come out because you are a lot. you will be able to contribute something to this planet that nobody else has ever contributed before or will again. When you know, when you're in your 20s, I think Oscar Wilde said this thing of youth is wasted on the young. I don't know if you've ever heard that. Oh, yeah. When you're in your 20s, there's still so much natural cheat, you know, natural kind of vitality.
这就是当有自动扶梯可用时，依然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特（Michael Easter），在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析我们这个奇怪的现代世界中关于心理坚韧度、体能和建立复原力的科学。我将与作家、研究人员以及其他健康和健身专家等展开对话，带大家看透主导健康产业的不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。我们真的相信种子油本质上会引起发炎。我们弄错了。我们在世界上感到恐慌的许多问题，其实都是压力的结果。经历一些艰难困苦，
Even if you're dealing with a chronic illness, it's a lot. different dealing with it in your 20s and let's say when you're in your 70s. And so if if the people who are in their 20s can really connect with the beauty that lies within them, with the potential that lies and really believe in it and form teams of people and friends that believe in them to cheerlead them on throughout their life. It's just 20-year-olds have everything they could give to the world. So that would be my deepest piece of advice. I think that's such a beautiful way to finish the episode. And also just a nice reminder that for anyone in their 20s who's listening, which is probably most people, like we are truly so young. And I always really appreciate
你最终会成为一个更快乐、更满足、更健康的自己。收听《2%》。即HeartRadio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方都可以找到名为“T-W-O-Percent”的节目。你还记得黛安娜·罗斯（Diana Ross）在VMA颁奖典礼上双击（拍打）莉尔·金（Lil' Kim）的胸部吗？或者当坎耶说乔治·布什不关心黑人时。我知道你在想什么。乔治·布什跟莉尔·金到底有什么关系？
when we have people who have a lot of wisdom come on the show who basically say some version of that, which is like, slow down, you have time, you're going to figure it out. I find that incredibly comforting. And I found so much of what you had to say incredibly informative and nourishing and made me see the world in a different way. So I really appreciate your wisdom and your knowledge. Thank you for coming on the show. It's an honor, Gemma. Thank you for doing the work you're doing for the world. Oh, of course. I'm going to leave all of Jessica's links down below, including the link to her book, the link to her school, and everywhere else you can find her. If you want to continue learning about breathwork, she is the source for you. I think she knows more than,
好吧，你可以在《回顾过去》（Look Back at It）播客中找到答案。我是萨姆·J（Sam J.）。我是亚历克斯·英格利士（Alex English）。在每一集里，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试着理解我们是如何熬过来的。包括最近一集请到了马克·拉蒙特·希尔（Mark Lamont Hill），畅谈80年代的霹雳瘾（crack）。需要说明的是，84年对我来说意义重大，不仅仅是因为crack。
more than about 99.999% of the people on this brilliant topic. Thank you again for listening. If you enjoyed this episode, make sure you share it with a friend or someone you believe would benefit from it. Make sure as well that you are following us on Instagram at That Psychology Podcast so you can know when new episodes go live, ask us questions, and just give feedback or join the conversation. But until next time, stay safe, be kind. Be kind. Be gentle with yourself. Breathe deeply, and we will talk very, very soon. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter, and on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness,
我随时都可以聊聊当年的crack，只是想让大家知道我的意思。我的意思是，马克，这是我们讨论crack的第二集了。所以我开始看出这里面有一条主线了。我们现在还把“艾滋病”摆在桌面上呢。谢谢你把那句话补充完整。我不认为对黑人来说还有比这更重要的年份了。真的吗？是的。
fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships,
对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人而言最重要的年份之一。请在iHeartRadio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《回顾过去》。欢迎来到我的新播客《迎难而上》（Learn the Hard Way），我是主持人、也是你最喜欢的治疗师基尔·盖恩斯（Keer Gaines）。为了庆祝心理健康意识月，我将带来我在心理健康领域十多年的经验，以及与许多不可思议的嘉宾的对话。我说的是：特里普·方丹（Tripp Fontaine）、瑞安·克拉克（Ryan Clark）。有时，当我们追求某样东西时，我们太过于沉迷于追逐本身，以至于没有意识到我们其实已经拥有了这件东西。然而我们还在继续追逐。
and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's T-W-O-Persent on the I-Hart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tap Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do with Little Kim?
并且我们不知道什么时候才算“够了”。因为人们总是在看记分牌。生活变成了关于输赢的较量。史蒂夫·伯恩斯（Steve Burns）、达斯汀·罗斯（Dustin Ross），因为你觉得在世期间做一个好人很重要吗？你做一个好人是因为你害怕吗？因为那是两种不同的动机，兄弟。
Well, you can find out on the Look Back at It podcast. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill, waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 was big to me, not just because of crack.
绝对是。那是两种不同层面的信任。我希望你只是真正地去做一个好人。加入我，我是基尔·盖恩斯，我们将就疗愈、成长、父爱、压力和个人发展展开真实的对话，就在我的新播客《迎难而上》中。
I'm down to talk about crack on day, but just so you all know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack. So I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now. Thank you finishing that sentence. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really? Yeah.
打开你免费的iHeartRadio应用。搜索《Learn the Hard Way》并立即收听。2023年，前《单身汉》（Bachelor）明星克莱顿·埃克德（Clayton Echard）发现自己卷入了一场亲子鉴定丑闻之中。随后的家庭法庭听证会暴露了他故事中明显的矛盾之处。这引发了一场长达数年的法庭之战来证明真相。森茨女士，你伪造了这个特定的测试两次，对吗？我只伪造了一次测试。
For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hardway with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Keer Games. And in recognition of Mental Health Awareness Month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking, Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we, are in possession of the thing. And we're still chasing it.
这需要一支互联网侦探大军来破案。我希望人们能够看到他们的纳税都被用在了什么地方。阳光是最好的消毒剂。他们将揭露一个令人不安的模式。还有两个经历过同样事情的男士。格雷格·吉莱斯皮（Greg Gillespie）和迈克尔·马兰蒂尼（Michael Marantini）。我的天啊，我震惊了。
And we don't know when we've done enough. Because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross, because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth? Are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro.
我是斯蒂芬妮·杨（Stephanie Young）。这是《爱的陷阱》（Love Trapped）。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯（Laura Owens）终于要面对后果了。女士们先生们，马里科帕县传来突发新闻，劳拉·欧文斯已被指控犯有欺诈罪。在亚利桑那州，正义得到伸张之前，这一切都不会结束。请在iHeartRadio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《爱的陷阱》播客。2%。这就是当有自动扶梯可用时，依然选择走楼梯的人的比例。
Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Kear Gaines, is we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and personal. on my new podcast, Learn the Hardway.
我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析我们这个奇怪的现代世界中关于心理坚韧度、体能和建立复原力的科学。经历一些艰难困苦，你最终会成为一个更快乐、更满足、更健康的自己。收听《2%》。即在iHeartRadio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方搜索TWA%即可收听。在《回顾过去》播客中。从1979年开始，那对我来说是一个重大的时刻。84年对我来说意义重大。
Open your free I Heart Radio app. Search Learn the Hardway and listen now. In 2023, former Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story. This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Sond's, correct? I doctored the test once.
我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利士。在每一集里，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试着理解我们是如何熬过来的。与我们的朋友、同僚喜剧演员以及最喜欢的作家一起。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔谈论80年代。那是一个疯狂的年代。那是一个疯狂的年代。我不认为对黑人来说还有比这更重要的年份了。
It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for. Sunlight's the greatest disinfected. They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Gregalespian and Michael Marantini. My mind was blown.
请在iHeartRadio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《回顾过去》。嘿，大家好，你们好吗？你们正在收听由你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人基尔·盖恩斯主持的《迎难而上》。这个空间专注于黑人男性的经历，进行坦诚的对话，这些对话在其他任何地方进行其实并不安全，但在这里是安全的。因为你在和一个懂行的持证专业人士交流。有多少男人穿着一套精神铠甲。它向世界发出信号，表明你是不好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你需要去对抗，
I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Americopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over until justice is served in Arizona. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available.
请在iHeartRadio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《迎难而上》。2023年，《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德被指控是双胞胎的父亲。但这场怀孕似乎是一场骗局。森茨女士，你伪造了这个特定的测试两次，对吗？我只伪造了一次测试。这需要一支互联网侦探大军来揭露一个令人不安的模式。还有两个经历过同样事情的男士。
I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWA% on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84's big to me.
格雷格·吉莱斯皮和迈克尔·兰西亚尼（Michael Ranciani）。我的天啊，我震惊了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《爱的陷阱》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于要面对后果了。请在iHeartRadio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《爱的陷阱》播客。这是一档iHeart播客。
I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a hear, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. with our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. It was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people.
保证全真人制作。本集暂无评论。点击转录文本中的任意句子即可发表评论。
Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hard Way with your favorite therapist and host Kier Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're not. you're having him with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you're not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to,
请在 iHeart Radio App、Apple Podcasts 或其他您获取播客的平台上收听“Look Back at It”。嘿，大家好！欢迎收听由您最喜爱的治疗师兼主持人 Kier Games 主持的《Learn the Hard Way》。这个节目旨在探讨黑人男性的经历，进行在其他地方可能并不安全、却充满坦诚的对话，而这一切都是在一位深谙此道的持证专业人士的陪伴下进行的。多少男人身披铠甲，向世界发出信号：你可不是好惹的。但这并不意味着只要你有这种能力，就一定要……
listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Owens, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing.
请在 iHeart Radio App、Apple Podcasts 或其他您获取播客的平台上收听《Learn the Hard Way》。2023年，《钻石单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德（Clayton Eckerd）被指控是双胞胎的父亲，但这场怀孕似乎是一场骗局。“欧文斯女士，你曾两次篡改这份特定的检测报告，对吗？”“我篡改了一次检测。”这起事件动用了大批网络侦探，才揭开了一个令人不安的模式：还有另外两个男人也经历过同样的事情。
Greg Gillespie and Michael Ranciani. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. This is an IHeart podcast.
格雷格·吉莱斯皮（Greg Gillespie）和迈克尔·兰西亚尼（Michael Ranciani）。我简直震惊了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨（Stephanie Young），这是《Love Trapped》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警方。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临了后果。请在 iHeart Radio App、Apple Podcasts 或其他您获取播客的平台上收听《Love Trapped》播客。这是一档 iHeart 播客。
Guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
保证真人。本集暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可留下评论。